[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis Invitational that
tradition continues with only three
rounds to go only seven players remain
across both fields out of an original
possible 14 that can still win their GM
or I am norms for the players eligible
to earn a norm the magic number is six
points six points out of nine we must
say that it is no guarantee that anybody
not even the winner of each field will
earn a norm that is a special occurrence
but in this tournament there is a
$15,000 prize fund the higher you score
the more money you make
as of this post there are three rounds
left and after Monday evenings event the
two round a day schedule is over so the
players can slow down and breathe a sigh
of relief
one round Tuesday one round Wednesday
and then playoffs if necessary to
determine first place in either field of
the four players tied for first in the
GM section two of them are grandmasters
the other two the hopefuls john burke
and daniel gurevich are ones to watch
can either of them earn a norm and
finish this tournament with what they
came for
by the time you see this video round
seven will probably be complete so the
game to watch for round eight on Tuesday
November 21 is John Burke versus Daniel
Gurevich in the International Master
norms section after six rounds I'm here
with the very charismatic
Vijay master Carissa Yip charissa today
you crushed Matt Larson's dreams of
getting a norm how do you feel fantastic
wonderful as she should so you had black
pieces against Matt take us through the
game and show us exactly what happened
I'm gonna sew like I had this fantastic
opening prep for him
wait am I supposed to say believes that
loud yeah yeah you can narrate this okay
the d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 Bishop
b4 up three c5 d5 d6 d4 and here usually
main move is castles but I played b5
instead and b5 is like the next move
after castles but b5 rather way sort of
limits White's options and so like the
example is after Knight g2 which is like
the main move after castles B takes c4
and then this is like pretty good for
black so metaphor takes so like I'm
playing the play Knight b6 so Queen a
for to win back the pond castles Queen
takes c4 Knight b6 Queen d3 night h5 and
so like the idea is to play f5 so we
played g4 here which I think like wasn't
really gonna move because when after
Queen h4 a king d1 and the King is like
swim 50 in the post game analysis Matt
suggested like f5 which was like some
game that's so played but didn't really
consider it because it's just like
hanging the night so thought night off
for was pretty good too Knight takes off
for a takes bishop takes
and basically the whole idea is like
giving up the pawn is going to be a lot
of tactics around this area the King
select Queen f6 and so I mean ideas
first if Bishop G free then Knight a for
with the double threat of the sea free
pawn and for combi - so King C chillin
like rook VA and I think box position
here is pretty good
so Bishop retreats back to d2 instead to
protect the pawn rook b8 and this was in
preparation for his next move I was
hoping he would play rook v1 and this is
sort of a blunder because the queen of
saw overloaded here so it bishop basics
and the idea is like so Queen has to
protect the x-ray pawn here
so if it doesn't take the bishop on a6
Queen III then Knight takes d5 and then
this work is hanging - so does the whole
idea of Bishop basics and way it's kind
of forced to take on a sixth Queen takes
a six Queen takes f3 community - Queen
takes h1 King c2 and I think like in
this position all white can really hope
for is like keeping my queen out of the
game and then he might stand a chance
but the king is still free a week over
here so not a four to exchange off the
works and then Petra and b2 so rookie
free c4 it's obviously if Queen takes c4
that night c5 and p4 is going to hang on
my Queens came back from the game so
Brooke before because he still doesn't
want to give up the B file rook takes
before C takes me for rook b8 with the
idea of displaying C free and then
taking upon before so a free Queen takes
c4 with an option I considered here but
I think after the Queen takes H to learn
I'm just much better so though it would
give him more of a fighting chance than
what happened in the game so a3 a5 so
King see you want to sort of a bad move
I guess he didn't really know what to do
here like I said earlier Queen takes c4
would still probably be best but he
played king c1 which I'm okay with
so it takes b4 there's like a
complicated line with C free here you
should go for it takes ticks ticks takes
you to Queen takes King c2 and I
couldn't really find any like outright
win for black I guess and this is just
sort of too complicated so I figured it
takes b4 it would just be the easiest so
Bishop takes me for because if a takes
line is c3
so between g1 and now the bishop can't
play we go to e free to stop my claim
from coming back in the game so King c2
rook c8 and then he just kind of came
desperate here and played ePHI because
like well the positions pretty much
already lost once the Queen comes back
to d4 so if i takes d6 Queen D for D 7
Queen takes D southern Queen takes e5
rook b8 so final touches like a fish up
you to the stop in d1 then rook e8 would
just be winning so we need to clean D
floor with mate on b2 so it can be won
in d1 King a - Queen B Cherie and he
resigned here because of King anyone
then look d1 and then
mate so very nicely done charissa thank
you for joining me down here I gotta ask
though I've been talking to a lot of
people who participate in these norm
tournaments and it always seems like the
norm is almost secondary you know it's
nice if you win in one but during the
games during the tournament you're not
really thinking about it too much
where do you stand on the issue um yeah
I think I sort of agree with that like
if I'm doing really well in the
tournament like and I have norm chances
and I'm flakes start to become like
fixated on that and then my place or
decreases or like try not to focus on
the possibility of the norm so now
you're just I mean you got to be
thinking of the prize fund at this point
there's a prize phone yeah there are
prizes for this tourney oh well I guess
that's a pleasant surprise okay well
something new to fight for Karissa
what's next for you after this
tournament I don't like to really have
anything big planned I guess so like
this is victor in las vegas around
christmas time like north american open
but plane tickets are really expensive
so i'm not gonna go
besides that not really much because
like I just died high school I'm really
busy with homework and stuff I'm sure
you are you know a high school and of
course college you know it's it's always
a lot of work well I'm sure we'll see
you back for one another Invitational
Tournament the US Women's Championship
something like that you thank you very
much for joining me charissa let's take
a look at the standings where two-thirds
of the way through in the i M norm
section in the last two rounds
Justin Wang has broken free of the rest
of the pack and he is in sole lead of
the i M norm section assuming round
seven has already happened round eight
has two big games Aaron grab in ski
against international master Torres and
Justin Wang versus Annie Wang catch the
remaining games moved by move as it
happens on chess 24 and u.s. chess
champs calm on Tuesday November 21 and
Wednesday November 22 both days at 11:00
a.m. playoffs on Wednesday at 4:00 p.m.
if necessary until next time then Simon
here for the st. Louis chess club so
long from the Show Me State